ici sur le boulevard en tête de la
manifestation une tenue un bras dessus
bras dessous comme habituellement nous
étions de jeunes et nous avons essayé
d'aller vers la bastide là on s'est
aperçu que toutes les rues étaient
touchés plusieurs rangs de policiers qui
étaient dans le noir avec on distingue
assez mal se sont rués sur le premier
rang et par une je ne sais pas un ordre
je ne sais pas lequel n'en sais rien ils
ont commencé à matraquer
[Musique]
il était en train de me dire respire et
ne bouge pas
respire je pars respire ne bouge pas
c'est tout c'est à dire sauf david
[Musique]
certains reller aux pilules cassez qui
est béton qui était transformée en
véritable vieux et qui tapait comme ça
verticalement donc avec la pointe de
dessin pieux sur sur les manifestants du
coucher à terre et qui avait aucune
possibilité de défense et de se protéger
il frappait et tout en frappant du ze5
communiste on va vous faire preuve et
les matériaux les travées tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient trouver il est jeté mais en
d'un confort sur les sur les gens qui
étaient en classe et dans la station de
métro j'avoue que en parlant maintenant
c'est même presque insoutenable de dire
avec
quelle férocité ont envoyé ces
des gens qu'on appelle des hommes
s'acharner sur cette population qui
venaient manifester sa volonté de paix
en algérie contre l'aurès
pensé qu' il ya eu sas c'est vraiment
du roi
[Musique]
c'est parfaitement scandaleux que on
n'est toujours pas reconnu la
responsabilité du gouvernement dans
cette répression c'est tout est plus
simple et a massacré un crime d'état je
sais parce qu'elles sont là bas quelle
est la bonne formule